it's the right side but they can't do
that yeah and uh sneaky move there by
wesley so actually wesley he realizes
that white's advanced pawn over on the
left side actually it still takes a
while to get forward and uh to promote
so black is going after white's pawn on
the right side but that's why magnus he
just kills all hope of counter play he
defends his remaining pawn remember the
pawn on the g line that's the winner
long term so he's uh he's just
protecting it with his rook and a check
kicks the black king even further away
oh
sadistic stuff from magnus and uh now i
he will just uh use his rook to attack
the pawn yep he can move it two squares
to the right
he can bring his rook across that pawn
on the f line now is about to fall
white's g pawn will eventually become a
queen wesley
he resigns he leans back and gives up
wow what a start you guys to the aim
chess u.s rap and the two top guys in
the meltdown champions chess store
magnus carlsen he won this game logging
off no smile to see from the world
champion but he must be so excited